open source forms the bones of our
digital infrastructure that undergirds
all of our daily activities
not unlike the roads and bridges that
keep us together in our physical world
understanding the maintenance costs of
this infrastructure then is key to
understanding how to care for our
digital future
you can see why the making part of
software would dominate the conversation
in open source
it's strange and compelling to think of
our entire digital world propped up by
the work of volunteer developers
who write open source because they enjoy
it but as it turns out
writing new code is only one small part
of maintaining software in reality the
majority of time spent on software is
not on making but maintenance
which makes up by some estimates
somewhere around 50 to 70 percent of a
typical software developer's work
and yet curiously much less conversation
has been spent on understanding the
maintenance of software
if you're familiar with open source
already you know that it runs on
contributions from developers all over
the world
a developer writes and publishes their
project online initially but once it's
up
anyone can contribute to it by
submitting changes to the project these
changes are reviewed by that original
developer
or by any other number of so-called
maintainers that they've recruited and
either accepted or declined
if you've ever used google docs it's
like suggesting edits where someone else
with edit permissions decides whether
your suggestion will make it
from an economics perspective
researchers typically explain open
source like this
developers are intrinsically motivated
to make and contribute to software
because they like hacking away on new
ideas
they share that code because they get
reputational rewards for showing off
their ideas
and software like other kinds of
information is zero marginal costs
meaning that the cost to produce it
doesn't increase with more users
said another way if i write and publish
my code on github the popular hosting
platform for open source projects
it should make no difference to me
whether 10 or 10 000 people want to use
it
the cost to me as a developer is the
same while this all sounds great in
theory
in practice economists are basically
saying that software doesn't have any
maintenance costs
or perhaps that maintenance is just as
intrinsically motivating and therefore
just as free as creation
but we know this just isn't true all
software does carry hidden ongoing
marginal costs
just not ones that people like to talk
about